are you single alone and in need of  something sweet in your life I have a  girlfriend oh just go along with it I'm  going to show you how to make an amazing  quickie microwave dessert for one let's  do it all right one diced Apple gonna  add about a half a tablespoon or so of  brown sugar plus a teaspoon of butter  then I added some cinnamon spice I'm  gonna pop this into the microwave for  four minutes until it's softened and  deliciously golden to top it off we got  some full fat Greek yogurt some toasted  pecans and a couple apple chips  all right let's recap we got lots of  fiber in our apples plus our apple chips  healthy fats and the pecans and lots of  protein in our Greek yogurt and it  literally took a few minutes to make  nature's candy  [Music]